this video is sponsored by longevity
technology
so hello and welcome to the sheiki
science show where in this video we're
going to talk all about the
interventions testing program
the itp and the seven compounds they've
identified
so far that can extend lifespan
significantly in mice
so i'll begin by introducing the itp
what it is
what are their aims and the principles
behind their work
then we'll jump straight into looking at
what they found out so far
discussing both the compounds that have
shown lifespan extension in mice and
those that haven't
and we'll also take a look at some sex
specific differences which are quite
interesting
and then lastly we'll talk about what
are their next steps and their next
compounds to be testing
in addition to what we can do with this
information in terms of its
translational potential to humans
so first then what actually is the itp
well it's a multi-site collaborative
project
funded by the national institute of
aging and their main goal is to identify
compounds that promote healthy aging
in a genetically heterogeneous mouse
model the idea is that by identifying
certain compounds
it can one have translational potential
for human use to improve human health
span with age
but secondly to provide evidence for
different pathways to underpin the aging
process
to further understand potentially other
targets for interventions
for example let's say one compound
identified by the itp
targeted factor x and we know that
factor x is interacting with factor y
then it would then be interesting to try
and identify compounds that could target
factor y
as they may be mediating lifespan
extension as well so the idea is about
building up a bigger picture of the
molecular underpinnings of the aging
process
and the motivation behind this work
comes down to the fact that aging is a
risk factor
for many different chronic diseases with
increased disease vulnerability and
death accumulating with age
and this is of great concern given the
change in demographics in the upcoming
years
and so in order to contain the
escalating increase in healthcare
spending
it is desirable to reduce the overall
burden of disability and chronic disease
and it's thought that a more
cost-effective approach would be to
target aging itself
instead of all the different
age-associated diseases separately
genetic studies and the testing of a
variety of different compounds
have shown in a variety of different
model organisms that aging can be
thought of as being adaptive and
amenable to these interventions
as they can extend both health plan and
lifespan and so the big
question is how much this information if
at all can it be translated to humans
and so this is kind of where the itp
come back in as their aim is to
take all this information that's
currently been published and to
capitalize on it by rigorously
evaluating
any potential agents that have promise
for human use
and so what do i mean by rigorously
evaluate well this comes down to the key
principles that the itp
use to make sure that they follow good
experimental design
and to improve the validity of any
results that they can get
so what are these principles well the
first principle is that they run these
tests
in parallel at three different sites so
this includes the jackson laboratories
one at the university of michigan
and one at the university of texas
health sciences center
at san antonio and so not only does the
setup mean that more expertise can be
brought into the programme
but it also provides reproducibility by
having the same interventions tested
at three different sites the next few
principles revolve around the mice that
they use in their studies
firstly they use genetically
heterogeneous mice referred to as um
het3
and so the way that they can get these
genetically heterogeneous mice is by
using a cross-breeding scheme
between different strains of females and
males and so none of the mice are
identical
but each mouse shares half of its genome
with every other mouse in the population
and so the population level diversity
can be replicated
and so the genetic heterogeneity is
reproducible
such that the experiments can be
replicated at any time by starting with
the same parental strains
and so you can think of the mice all
being siblings to each other with the
perspective of their nuclear genome
and the advantages of having genetic
heterogeneity
basically reduces the possibility that
there was any strain specific
characteristics
that might be influencing the outcome in
this case the lifespan of the mice to
the different interventions
the second principle with the mice is
that they have a lot of them
each of the sites has 44 males and 36
females in each test treatment
the reason that there are more males
than females is due to the fact that
they can often lose males due to
fighting
and then for the control group they have
twice the number of mice so
88 males and 72 females and the reason
for these numbers
is due to a protocol developed by two
statisticians
which show that groups of this size
would detect a 10
change in mean lifespan with 80 power
even if data from one of the sites was
lost because of a systematic failure
and so the idea is you get power in
numbers and then the last principle
that's worth mentioning is their
unusually collaborative programme
by which they engage the broader
research community in the search for
agents that slow aging and extend mao's
lifespan
in fact they make an annual call for
proposals to the research community
and proposals are accepted from all
scientific quarters
whether it's in the us foreign
universities commercial entities or even
individuals without
institutional affiliations and so far
the itp have received more than 150
different proposals
out of these they've whittled their
number down to 43 agents that they've
actually tested
with increased longevity being seen in
the mice in at least one of the sexes
for seven of these 43 agents
but before i mention what these seven
agents are and some of the agents that
haven't been successful in increasing
lifespan
it's worth just mentioning how the
program is actually designed
as you can see in the schematic that i'm
drawing out after evaluation of the
prospective compound that's been
proposed
chosen compounds initially enter stage 1
whereby it focuses on lifespan as the
primary endpoint
compounds that seem promising in terms
of significantly extending lifespan in
the mice
then proceed to stage 2 which follows up
positive findings from stage 1 with
additional lifespan studies and can also
include
those response studies where appropriate
as well as a wide array of health
measurements
and cross-sectional pathology analysis
now the caveat with all this is that by
focusing on lifespan measurements
and omitting most physiological
assessments from stage 1
could in principle miss discoveries or
compounds that do
promote specific health outcomes but
don't necessarily alter mortality risk
and mice
however if these additional measurements
were included in stage 1
it has the downside that it would reduce
the number of compounds that could be
tested each year
so now for the book that you're probably
most interested in what are the seven
different compounds that have shown life
extension
in the mice well i'm going to give them
to you now and
to add a bit of fun i'll give them in
the order by the strength of the
conclusions
and depth of the supporting evidence
that they have so far for each one
so we'll go from good to last good i
suppose
so first up is rapamycin and that was
shown to extend
mean and maximal longevity in both sexes
when started at either 9 months or 20
months of age
and so rapamycin is an antifungal
antibiotic that was first isolated from
an easter island soil sample
and has been approved by the fda for its
immunosuppressive and anti-rejection
properties
the properties of rapamycin are thought
to be achieved by its inhibition of the
mammalian target of rapamycin
mtor which promotes growth signaling
within a cell
with enter activity being regulated by
nutrients growth factors and the
cellular energy status
and so follow-up studies into rapamycin
were performed to see if there were any
dose dependencies whereby if higher
doses of rapamycin are more effective
and that's basically what they saw with
the highest dose they used for rapamycin
resulting in a 26 extension of the
median lifespan of females
and 23 in males and interestingly
rapamycin
also produced a dose-dependent decrease
in liver degeneration in male mice
however at the high-dose treatment of
rapamycin
it was seen in both sexes that there was
more cataract severity than control mice
and another detrimental effect of
rapamycin is testicular degeneration
which was significantly elevated by all
three doses of rapamycin
and so therefore it seems likely that
the therapeutic dose of rapomycin
will vary for different pathologies and
that evidently more research is required
to look into rapamycin or rapamycin
alternatives
known as rapalogues the second compound
that extended lifespan of both male
and female mice was a-carbose
supplementation
and so a-carbose is a drug that is
approved for the clinical treatment of
diabetes
it works by inhibiting alpha glucosidase
which therefore
inhibits intestinal digestion of
carbohydrates and so it's thought in
this manner that
a cowboys can help to lower blood
glucose levels hence the reason why it's
prescribed for diabetes
however it's not sure if it's the
blunting of these surges and blood
glucose levels that can account for the
effect on mouse lifespan
in these studies and so to investigate
this further the itp are now completing
a survival analysis of mice treated with
chemically flosin
which is also thought to boast these
glucose spikes and so i guess if there's
a benefit with this compound
it would potentially support the role of
high glucose peaks as a modulator of
aging rates in mice
which is now making me rethink that
cream egg i just ate
anyway it's important to also point out
that acaba has led to a much stronger
effect on median lifespan in males than
females
and indeed follow-up work seems to have
shown male-specific improvements in
insulin sensitivity and glucose
tolerance the next compound
also showed sex specificity only
improving lifespan in male mice
this compound is nor dihydroguaritic
acid
better referred to as ndga which is far
more easier to say
so ndga is an antioxidant compound
found in the creosote bush which has
been used in traditional medicine and
has since been investigated in the lab
and has been shown to modulate the
activity of nrf2
and also more recently shown to be able
to activate autophagy
however i think this is still a bit
under-investigated moreover the
sex-specific difference is also very
interesting
and i should also point out at this
point that all of these
survival charts can be accessed on the
mouse phenome database websites
which is where the itp will upload all
of their latest data
and so there's a variety of different
possibilities to why there could be sex
specific differences
for example it could be that the
metabolism of these compounds
vary between different genders or it
could be that male specific pathways
relating to aging are being targeted
or it could be that there are some
negative consequences
on lifespan for females as opposed to
males and the reason why i emphasize the
fact that there could just be so many
differences between
males and females is the fact that the
fourth compound that
they mention is 17 alpha estradiol which
also shows an increased male lifespan
but not female lifespan
so what is 17 alpha estradiol well it
isn't
17 beta estradiol which is the most
biologically active
and abundant estrogen in circulation
instead the alpha form
is considered a non-feminizing hormone
with reduced affinity for the estrogen
receptor
and whilst i think further studies are
required to understand the molecular
mechanism
of 17 alpha estradiol it has been shown
in follow-up studies by the itp
that metabolomic changes seen in the 17
alpha estradiol treated male mice
were in general not seen in females or
in males castrated
prior to treatment suggesting that the
drug effects require the presence of
testicular hormones
and the next compound is protandim a
patented
compound which is actually a mixture of
botanical extracts
that is thought to activate an rf2 and
i'm not really going to talk too much
about this one
partly because while we're only extended
median lifespan of males
not females but also because there
really isn't that much
known about it besides these itp studies
so
i think i'm just going to leave it at
that for now in sixth place we have food
supplemented with glycine that resulted
in a significant lifespan extension
in both males and females but the effect
in males was larger than in females
both at the median lifespan and at the
90th percentile marks
but the longevity effects in general
were quite small and did not much alter
median survival age
but the reason they tested glycine was
due to the fact that glycine
supplementation is thought to be able to
mimic
methionine restriction due to the role
that glycine plays in methionine
metabolism
and restriction of methionine was shown
to extend lifespan in rats and mice in
previous studies
and just in case you didn't know
methionine and glycine are both amino
acids
so they are building blocks of proteins
and so that finally leads on to the
seventh compound
which drumroll plays is
aspirin which is commonly used as an
anti-inflammatory agent
and that was only shown to significantly
extend male lifespan and the sex
specific differences in this case
seems to be due to the fact that females
tended to have
a higher relative rate of metabolism of
aspirin
so it's less active metabolites
salicylate
but more interestingly when these
results were replicated in male mice
with two higher doses
there wasn't a longevity benefit and so
additional studies would be needed to
understand these conflicting results
and so it's also worth mentioning a
couple of compounds that haven't shown
any lifespan extension in the mice at
the doses
used in these studies this included
curcumin
fish oil green tea extract resveratrol
and metformin although as i said earlier
you can see the full list on the mouse
phenome database website
but it is worth mentioning in the case
of metformin that when they combined
metformin with rapamycin it had an
enhanced
effect on lifespan compared to rapamycin
alone
so that just goes to show how these
studies do just have
one compound at a specific dose and that
it could be that combined with something
else could be
more beneficial and i suppose in some
ways there's kind of point holes in the
limitations of the itp study
but as i mentioned earlier there has to
be some kind of trade-off
into how they can robustly test as many
compounds as possible
with the fact that some of the compounds
may be promising but are missed off due
to the way that they
purely focus on lifespan for their
primary endpoints
and in terms of their latest data at the
time of their most recent update which
was
earlier this year there are several
stage 1 studies that were essentially
complete
or in preparation for peer review and
this included longevity data for
nicotinamide ribosides
and canoglyflosin as well as a test of
alternate dosing schemes for rapamycin
comparing continuous treatment
with periodic treatments in monthly
cycles
so it's interesting and exciting to see
what compounds
are extending lifespan and mice but how
much can this be translated to humans
well for an intervention to be
translatable it would be desirable to
satisfy
some of the following conditions
including low toxicity well actually
that would be a definite you'd want to
satisfy that
with few side effects have effective
oral administration
have effective stability and scalability
and low manufacturing costs
be detectable in blood and be effective
when administered later life or once
symptoms have already started to develop
and another consideration given that
there are already sex specific
differences
in these different compounds would be to
take into account all of the different
diet environmental
gender ethnicity polymorphisms and age
variables that make all of us unique as
this could also impact how beneficial
these compounds are
but all in all the work from the itp is
very encouraging
and is taking us that step closer to
understanding the aging process
so with that i'd like to thank the
sponsor for this video longevity
technology for which i am very grateful
longevity technology deliver high
quality daily news and insights on
research investments and technologies
that extend health span and lifespan
find the link to their website in the
description
so i hope you've learned something in
this video thank you to my patreon
supporters
and thank you for listening